all right I'm back I have two pending
challenges so I was testing this last
night and I haven't used it on streem
yet but its first time for for
everything I don't know if anyone's
watching yet but we're going to open up
the council people actually can't see
cuz its off-screen I could show behind
the scenes view of the council and
yesterday I was going through random
YouTube comments and there is someone
that shared like a snippet of code okay
it got caught by the spam filter on
YouTube but somehow I was like looking
through the comments in the filter and I
found it this is a code if people can't
see the whole thing but essentially it's
going to accept a random challenge so
I'm gonna press Enter hey it works okay
this isn't gonna make life much much
easier cuz I've had problems in the past
with indecisiveness and when I have like
over 30 40 pending challenges I can just
use that command that will be great
valley ryan and the chat my opponents
saying you actually accepted did i
actually accept or was it the random
algorithm accepting i guess i play the
role in it
hello to podcast ik do i play a fried
liver someone wanted me to play a fried
liver like this is another youtube
comment i read i think it was wait is
he's playing the Traxler okay so against
the track so i know to take with check
and then i think to move back to the
square i don't know much beyond this so
this is a new position for me
and it's blitz is casual I could fork
mean forking looks really nice don't see
anything wrong with it I think black was
supposed to play Queenie eights if I'm
not mistaken Queen a fates this is still
interesting actually
I really don't know anything about the
track sir so the fact that black might
be having some italic barely talked I
don't know T stuck in my throat
I'll wash it down with more tea
if I take the rook takes on f2 takes on
f2 Knight takes e4 King III Queen f2
King takes e4 I'm probably just getting
mated after a Bishop f5 so if I take the
rook takes on f2 King f1 Knight takes e4
Queen f3 but takes a rook takes on f2
King f1 there's Bishop to g4 in my queen
is trapped so let's not mess with these
lines I could bleed D no D 3 d3 looks ok
actually still trying to do things but
I'm ready to castle I'm ready to play
Bishop g5 I'm still attacking the rook
this should still work out hopefully so
focused on the opening I have not been
really looking at the chat hello to
people erode ito podcast ik sugar 9 so
many nines probably influenced by Ben
fine gold Knight d4 okay that's a good
sign that like blacks not really
attacking anything I could take the rook
I could play Bishop g5 let's play Bishop
g5 I like my Knights
it's like blocking the Queen hello - its
South LA Liat
kind of pink Jake what's increment you
can challenge me to any time control I
oh I forgot about that move okay I
should focus I think I'm gonna take here
first and then take the rook black will
take my rook and it's just a whole mess
am I gonna be down a piece and then I
might be down a piece because my Knights
getting trapped okay I messed that up
big time now I have to fight back like
earlier today I was hanging pieces left
and right by once on the game's I
shouldn't have so ok Knight takes you to
interesting desperado I have to take so
hopefully this will be a lesson in like
fighting back from down material it's
still kind of complicated I have a 95
blacks underdeveloped giving me c7 let's
take c7 hitting the rook expecting this
he has bishop before Bishop before it's
probably a mistake though so I play King
me to then I'm threatening this as well
I think I'll Castle what's castle and I
want to play b4 I want to be sneaky and
set up tactics
what's the pawn count I have a pawn for
a minor piece it could be worse could be
better too though my opponent I don't
know when my opponent said this he said
damn I kind of forgot this line well I
forgot it's much worse or I just messed
it up this is coming bishop h3 but
Bishop h3 there is some trick before
Bishop h3 Queen b3 we trade
doesn't quite work unfortunately I mean
I have Queen b3 immediately I have 25
seconds to it's not much time let's play
King h1 just prophylaxis I still want to
do this maybe I have 95 as well at some
point my opponent saying my videos are
nice sending me compliments as he's like
beating me can't get distracted though
I'm not looking at the chat focusing on
the game this is an idea this is an idea
there's a few resources even f4 which I
didn't even realize because my pawn is
unpinned and the rook is aligned with
the King so there's multiple ideas and
black has to still like develop some
pieces and I have to drink some more tea
okay Bishop III so let's be sneaky ah
but he wants to okay i'll LA
Bishop e6 Bishop e6 live Knight b5 to
attack the pawn probably rook d8
I can pawn storm with a 5 we're both
getting low on time
it's gonna be a time scramble ok so I
think he just plundered because I
wouldn't back the piece
and materials going to be equal actually
it's a Christmas miracle
oh do I do D for very thematic to open
the center maybe I for at some points
I'm gonna go after the D pawn but it's
defended let's play this threatening to
win the rook expecting rook g8 and then
I probably have to play g3 that's also a
move let's play f4 I just want to open
more lines and move quickly enough and
not get that great mated this looks
decent King Yeates the problem is my
rook can't really get in check
I'm just going to go back to f2 I didn't
see anything better
it's black on a flag I'm attacking the
pawn winning the pawn winning another
pawn he's gonna win he four okay let's
do this and then maybe each three maybe
this just defend everything yeah lift
for the King every time I say aloof all
the German viewers get excited let's do
this okay there's gonna be some tactics
of Queen d7 Burke f7 if that's then this
Queen f8 coming ooh
trying to figure out how do I win this I
mean I'm gonna check and gain some time
maybe try and confuse him he's not
getting confused though let's do this
I'm just moving back maybe I'm getting
confused I'm losing this pawn Oh Queen
trade is nice
because I have a outside passer but he's
in the box so let's bring the king in
and this is a decoy okay
life is good I really have to go back
and look at the opening I'll go back and
look at the chat to GM Don John Davis is
back good to see you back
good evening it's more like good morning
it's 12 27 am very late night stream my
sleep schedule is messed up because I
was sick yesterday and I slept like in
the afternoon for too long yeah let's
take a look at this opening because it's
actually very very venomous if if
White's not well prepared are you going
to accept a challenge today yes I'm
accepting challenges if you want to
challenge me I have a new system and for
those who just joined you'll see what
the system is before I go any further
I'll just try and see what people are
doing in the chat what time controls do
I usually play against you guys anything
like 10 plus 2 and below John Davis if
you want a game I would I would accept
if you want to challenge me people can
use a challenge command which it seems
like everyone's doing what's a good rule
of thumb for when it's too late to
castle when you lose castling rights and
it's it's really too late
how'd I do in the arena kings I got
tilted but then I tilted some of my
opponents it was a mixed result uh can
we expect GM rosin not anytime soon
I do own the domain name GM rosin calm
just in case
but I'll be an item for a while loofa
okay alright quick question you know red
and game read online that swing that
game is important for chess how do you
go about studying and games get an
endgame book I recommend there's a few
in-game books I recommend one is 100 n
games you must know or something along
those lines by hey-zeus de la vela very
good author also those Sillman zine game
so men's complete and game course I have
them linked on my websites am i a bit
quiet turn your volume up or I'll try
and speak louder I have my mic balancing
on a flashlight so it's my new mic stand
also when it comes to any games like I
would encourage people so like find
players their own strengths like find a
training partner and if you're working
on certain end games especially
theoretical end games play the positions
out for both colors against a training
partner like take a position from a book
set it up like online or or over the
board play it out for both sides that's
how I've studied like over the years
especially like at least in recent years
when I compete for for like collegiate
teams so I went to two different
universities it's a good training method
also for openings - oh it's not quiet
okay that's good alright so Oh what am i
doing before I accept another challenge
I just want to look at the theory here
because King e7 a Bishop d5 but Bishop
e3 also playable in my opponent play
Queen or played d6 which actually it's
rare but it scores well for black in the
database
doesn't seem like blacks should have too
much compensation but I mean people play
this opening because there is this these
weird ideas and the king is surprisingly
safe on e seven times are just turn on
sock fish and see how it refutes this
line C three looks and actually see
three Queenie at D 3 maybe see three
prevents like 94 ideas d3 immediately
I played nine f7 yeah if I take the rook
I think I just lose -7 cuz Bishop takes
f2 like I have no moves here if I don't
save the bishop there's Bishop g4 and if
I take the bishop
it's like mates I was looking at this
line this is a hilarious line but not
for me what up neat so things got weird
Knight d4 is also actually interesting
here and then i blundered I forgot
Knight takes b3 was a threat I should
just take on h8 it's still a little bit
complicated because takes takes and then
takes on enough - ah king d2 and black
Oh blocks winning Wow
although line so night xb3
I have to take with the C pawn this is
insane because then I have a place on c2
to hide my king that's ridiculous
if the pawn were on c2 rather than a -
my King wouldn't have anywhere to go
crazy or is it to move the Queen what's
the winning line after ATX b3 King Ditu
Bishop g4 so it's maybe to put the Queen
on c2
what does this line 95 takes even stock
fish stock fish keeps going back and
forth between like 0 and -1 queena for
king c 3 now it's just settling on
perpetual ok more comments in the chat
no love for defer at ski endgame annual
um well of course there's love for it a
lot of the top players recommend it it's
a heavy book but yeah certainly I mean
it's kind of the Bible of n games - I
should probably list it on my site
training partner has been so helpful
play classical games and certain
openings with a friend prepare lines
yeah that's that's what I did for some
time like I was in a slump for several
years before I got my IM title and I
worked with a training partner and
within a few months I gained 100 points
so don't underestimate the power of
training with someone
my friends were bad at chess you need
new friends Joe Bruin hello and hello to
everyone I didn't say hello to were you
at the high school state championship in
Illinois the team championship not this
year I was in Africa a few weeks ago
when it took place I'll be at the
national championship though taking
place I think next week alright so
you're gonna do some more magic with
JavaScript if I'm sure there's a lot of
people who didn't catch the very
beginning of the stream but here I'm
gonna open up how I do this yeah I'm
opening up the council another behind
the scenes view here's my council then I
do this command I have 27 pending
challenges so if you challenge me you
have a 1 in 27 chance we're using math
dot random which is
I mean is anything truly random close
enough to truly random accept and the
lucky opponent or unlucky opponents so
we'll find out Francisco the creator
let's play or I guess I could take
opening recommendations to the base mile
openings off what I remember people
telling me from like previous streams
whoa that's really small Lord what Thanh
thanks for subbing oh Henry Lord Vuitton
appreciate it I remember a couple of
days ago someone was recommending this
line which is actually really
interesting
if black isn't prepared the idea is
after Queen h4 to play King f1 maybe in
similar style to the track sir which we
just saw I lose castling rights but I
get quick developments in this case I'll
still invite Queen h4 I would still like
to go for this line where I have knight
Knight f3 with tempo oh you play the
Kings gambit Kings gambit is one of
these openings where it can be a
surprise if Box not expecting it by the
flocks prepared I think there's there's
many different ways to equalize but it's
still playable i no naka his play that
carlson has played it he von Schuch
played it
Evon shook beat nakamura and some like
rapid championship with it and i
honestly don't really know any theory i
just know that you're supposed to
control the center and do stuff maybe
someday when back the pawn with this
bishop play English
English is another opening I played
recently I have a video sitting on my
desktop which I'm about to upload to
YouTube
it's called English versus Dutch as a
fun opening so Bishop c5 I think was
just a mistake like usually black does
want the bishop here but not when white
can play d4 and now I mean this is like
this is what you teach kids like how you
develop perfectly or an ideal setup
I'm ready to play e5 maybe even Knight
g5 also castling this is actually really
nice nice thing about the King's gambit
is like the half-open F file like the
rook on f1 Bishop here the possibility
of oh damn I'm losing a pawn I
completely forgot he could take on e4
well now it's a true gambit guy won back
my pawn happening another pawn but is he
brave enough to take on e4 because it
opens a file Wow so brave yeah now I
have to figure out how to justify this
I mean Queen e2 is the obvious move and
it forces Queen e7 and I could take on
c7 and there's d6 but d6 isn't really
too threatening
AHA but Queen e2 castling takes rook e8
I should be okay for white let's start
with Queen e2
this is getting interesting if I don't
win material back I'll probably still
have some compensation like I have more
development I have the bishop hair I can
still sort stir up some like initiative
d5 ideas I could just castle allowing
Knight takes c3
[Music]
there's this crazy move Bishop takes f7
I don't think it works King takes out
795 takes takes nah if I Castle now
let's castle not doing anything to
forcing putting the ball in blacks
courts allowing a knight takes c3 now I
have a choice so I could play queen d3 I
could take and win ce7 taking on f7
could be fancy King takes Queen c4
choices choices
I like Bishop takes f7 I don't see
anything wrong with it like I win back
the night and then the E and I file are
both open and I'll get my rooks there
and like box two major pieces are on
both files
wait chess calm using bad words in the
chat oh no I saw the star star star
shout out to chess comm I was playing
there earlier it's playing a lot of
strong players I play the Rena Kings I
had one goal for arena Kings to play
naka and I failed I struggled to like
get into the top 50 but this game I'm
not failing
I'm forking I'm winning the Knights I'll
gather rook wait rook e1 just pins and
wins and rhymes wait 94 though
it's trying to be poetic wait 94 I just
take it and that also pins and wins
cause Ricky won it's like a pin 94
followed by another pin and then the
last pin but how much material am I
losing for the Queen so I think in the
end I'll be down well I'll have a queen
but black will have two rooks and a pawn
but black will be underdeveloped so it
should be okay I think and black is
thinking I'm missing things in the chats
whoa big word what does bicurious mean
bicurious when you're curious about two
things do I dare ask Syria what this
means
what does bicurious mean series confused
my opponents confused too probably
trying to move the Queen away being
unable to or trying to castle oh it's so
nice like in chess even when you're down
material when you're just completed with
development okay so that's a good sign
because now I'll win the night or I'll
just be mating somehow but how okay I
feel like this is puzzle rush ish takes
and puzzle rush has trained me for these
moments where you have to find like the
quickest force mates otherwise you fail
I think it's made in three like one wait
no he blocks with night though okay I'm
not gonna spend too much time and energy
let's just take what look threatening
made in one I don't think black can
actually stop it
because if this and I'd meet oh you
stopped it so check wait work takes
takes Queen f7 there there there there
there is ninety to meet in the end let's
do it if this were chest calm I would
like multi pre move and finish with 92 I
guess I can singular pre move but I
can't even buy pre move okay wait what
am I thinking what was the line already
forgetting this oh but here's King e6
there there
okay well I'll hope for King efore if he
knew six all just repeats it's
definitely not the most efficient way
okay ninety-two mates that was nice
wasn't going to be the most efficient if
King e6 were played
all right oh just calm has left but
before leaving said Eric you're so cute
I'll take that as a compliment okay
let's move on
was there any was there anything to look
at that game was this oh no it was just
for good Kings gambits I think yeah
let's move on new challenge command wait
command option I to bring up the council
math dot random enter new challenge this
is beautiful
his other day I was trying to figure out
like creative ways to accept challenges
oh this is bullets this is rated okay
have to focus I'll play this line with
h5 it's dubious against okay now I don't
know what's going on just have to play
normally and quickly don't think he
should have taken with F on I have
mating attacks is there a force made
idea maybe kingi let's play key to
connect the rooks check
say with Bishop and I'll go for rook
okay always play off 3G for maybe coming
or just free Bishop okay I'm gonna go
for a knight g5 actually let's know
Knight gc3 is a threat so let's play 90
for stopping Knight g3 and then I'll go
for 96 still ideas of g4 for let's ooh
that was interesting let's do this okay
let's take pretty sure I can win this
check mate there we go okay well that
was quick let's do another random
challenge and see how many we can get
through you would eat I'm not even gonna
read this comment it's it started off in
such a way that it seemed readable
it started off Eric you're so good at
chess we'll just leave it at that
we chess math dot random okay chess
poems okay let's do a competition
whoever can write the best chess poem in
the chat gets to play the next game and
I'll be the judge you have to write a
poem you can't write multiple poems you
just have to write one poem best poem
wins
I would like to meet let's play Knight
g4 and I'm inevitably going to sacrifice
it's just a matter did I take with
bishop do I take with rook do I take
with Knight
this looks nice hitting the King King
had to move to g3 and now it's maybe
this training Queen f4 and Queen f6 also
pins a knight so like if 92 I can just
take the bishop but I'll probably just
be going after the king also ideas of
this this and this this looks really
difficult for for white okay well did
anyone write a poem john davis quoting
me not a bad quote my developer i have
some programming experience but i don't
consider myself a developer only in the
opening that's when i'm a developer
okay chess pawns game on the Kings board
I like chess it is the best when I play
I make a mess I lose and get mad and
flip the table huh okay this guy wins
Burks you get to challenge me wait
there's more the Danish gambit how bad
does he think I am whoops I lost my
queen
it's not bad Burks is still leading it's
now a gambits I said and then cried over
my blunder Queen interesting haiku every
time someone's saying
haiku I'm thinking akaru there's got to
be a poem or an anagram even with like
Hikaru haiku something man developer
joke was pretty bad in a good way okay
I'm gonna play Burks please oh wait john
davis is challenging me okay I'll play
john davis first and then i'll play
Burke's first time were ever playing you
said he plays Kings gambit that's only
information I know let's play before see
what he does plain I have three d6
okay I'm gonna play there should be five
check avoid any like annoying theory
Bishop g7 let's take another castle I'll
try and play this in an aggressive
fashion I think the most aggressive move
here is e five that's the type of move
if black is prepared it should be about
equal ninety-five
that's a new move for me usually Bach
takes 95 I think I could play Knight c3
the thing about this line if black isn't
careful liking at a very substantial
lead in development hello to Ramsay Shan
it's a lot of excellence okay so I could
take and rookie one Queen e2 ideas that
looks nice I'll play rookie one first
it's another theme where like I'm just
castled and I have a efile in this case
it's about to open what time is it it's
12 54 in the morning slightly late or
slightly early depending on your
perspective would you recommend dropping
out of school to pursue chess as a
career
[Music]
probably not as a player yeah probably
not
King g8 uh well the Kings off the e-file
but it's not out of danger let's play d4
I want to go for a dish of g5 maybe even
h e5 also on the triple box pawns it
takes
it's just triple bonds and the only
developed pieces is Queen on d7 so c4 is
logical try and keep the center closed
so I'm looking at Bishop g5 King c8 and
maybe b3 let's start with Bishop g5 if
there should be seven I can take on d6
I'm expecting the service King c7 could
still play b3 Bishop f4 also kind of
attractive let's start with b3
I want to attack from all angles ideally
I would love to open the C file like if
takes takes gather rook to see one would
be nice
am I playing viewers yes I'm just going
to assume that all my opponents are
viewing but maybe I'm playing some
people who are in a few and just
randomly challenged me h6 is logical
let's move back line with the king
this looks really difficult for luck the
center is about to open up
let's see takes d5 takes we'll just play
d5 it should be working those takes
takes I got a 95 if the night doesn't
take IV six yeah something went terribly
for black it's for you six hey Eric big
fan of your content I see some people
saying that chess is a low variance game
but not a no variance game I don't
understand where the variance comes from
I know if I understand that either
there's more variance and like poker
yeah I would need some context like
things can vary there's many different
elements that can vary okay I have a
pawn on e6 Queens blockading I would
love to get a Knight to d5 but that
would take a while maybe just this
attacking the knight pinning the pawn so
be six can't be played if the knight
moves way I can take this guy
also ideas of this in this
life is good challenge me to anything
like ten plus two or below because I
don't want to play like a really long
game let's take the pawn when I was
playing earlier today I was getting
winning positions and then just getting
like really careless and blundering
which is a really important like
psychological kind of situation which
happens in chess when you're better you
get careless so sometimes it takes extra
effort to stay focused okay I'm gonna
put the rook on d1
and go after this pawn even ideas with
like Queen c5 still ideas of this - this
pawn is very very tender and juicy like
a steak okay so let's move wait Bishop
takes rook takes I don't know if I want
to trade off maybe I can do this and
what the threat is
maybe Queen let's play Queen b5 that's a
good time for the steak steak steak
emote okay so I'm threatening made in
one black defense
there's some interesting trick it'll
play see for the ideas to play C 5 and
if takes c5 I could take on c6 which is
actually just made into because rook b8
would be mates it's all about removing
this pawn to open up the bishop or just
meeting like this
GG John Davis 59 I wonder if he played
worse cuz he doesn't have the GM title
in front of his knee like he does in the
twitch chat yeah next time take the pawn
I don't think 95 is ninety five has been
played before
Anaka play this against Cal fent yeah
the key thing to like know if you're
black in this line is if light goes for
e5 in 95 Queen c7 is a bad move you want
to play Queen CAS if you like Queen see
it and then like do some simple setup
it's actually not so bad but a lot of
people will go wrong with Queen c7 we
can see based on their like percentage
to be chess I would think it's more
drastic Queen c7 most popular the
problem is after a d4 he takes d4 and
Bishop f4 this is really difficult for
black like White's Castle the Queen's
are target's some cases where you even
like go back to c8
so yeah but Queen see it immediately
useful to know so how did not go wind
Queen f3 oh yeah this b3 idea is
actually quite nice
because the bishop has a long-term
pressure I think black probably
equalized some positional fights
I feel like black was doing fine
stockfish maybe slightly I don't know
okay let's save the GM analysis for some
other time let's play someone else well
I was gonna play Burks for writing that
beautiful poem which I already forgot
about every hue hoped oh I don't see
Burks Burks what's your last name if you
want to play me people are still writing
poems there is no more poem contest wait
to delay I'll get I'm sorry full layout
got messed up was it like that
oh no cuz I was searching time oops
there we go oh you were hoping I go for
a dragon or night or so someone was
asking me in that my discord today
what's my least favorite opening I gave
like three three different openings but
one of them was night or if I I hate
like the theory and I like sidelines hey
Eric can you
I play you if you want to play me
challenge me did Burke's respond oh
you're not playing you don't actually
like chess oh you just like streamers of
chess okay fair enough so I'll do
another random challenge command option
i random okay I'm playing Bozkurt 10
minutes rapid rated if I win this game
oh I should have played the English
someone was asking I'm playing a London
if I win this game
I break 2,400 there's a lot on the line
I will not marry you
the real donkey pride let's play 92 how
does the JavaScript work I'm pretty sure
it works through like magic a six a six
is usually a waste of time I mean
obviously black wants to play b5 I've
actually taught this to a student who is
encountering like a6 b5 usually the
strategy for white is to allow b5 and
then hit it with a 496 slightly unusual
let's play c3 I want to play Bishop d3 I
don't want to allow night before who's
stronger me or chess Network have you
seen my biceps more importantly have you
seen chest networks biceps I don't know
we've had a lot of one-minute battles I
think you were pretty even in one minute
we should play like some slower time
controls that would be fun actually to
do more streamer collaborations what's
my favorite London system tactic hmm
well I have a whole course with like 50
tactics in the London my favorite one
like my favorite one is towards the
beginning of the course I'm trying to
remember
like the Greek gift one is pretty nice
I could play four right away before I
think I'll just castle and see what
black is up to I'm waiting for black to
Castle so that I can start attacking 95
right away looking for tactics here I
want to play a four I'm looking at these
lines with like a 4 B 4 and then like we
trade doesn't seem to lead to much so
I'm considering ideas like Queen c2 or
Queen b1 just to yeah just to increase
some pressure along this line and also
along this line because now there's a
variation like here here maybe that
doesn't work though because you can
attack my bishop but there's also ideas
of efore here it could be interesting
what's the best way to respond to people
who play C 5 c4 against London you let
them do it and then you look to play the
pawn break either B 3 or a 4 and
depending on the situation either of
these pawn breaks can be quite powerful
but they play c4 in your bishops on d3
usually you want to drop back along this
diagonal and then usually 4
so the problem for lack in this position
it's hard to like figure out what to do
like there's so little active play as
I'm controlling these two squares very
nicely there's no clear pawn breaks
maybe before maybe black will do this
and see what I'm doing what's the st.
George defense sounds very familiar h6
interesting move efore takes takes takes
takes I'm gonna start with a four Wow
played so quickly I think that's just a
mistake though because I can I mean I
could take on d6 but okay takes takes
takes takes now let's just take on b5 if
if he takes on that four I take back
with pawn and this is basically a fork I
just won two pawns I have not lost a
single pawn yet this pawn well defended
let's play 95 Queen b6 might come wait
another free pawn I got three pawns oh
he can win this guy attacking the rook
what happens in the slide take steak
steak steak steaks I think that's good
for me
I won't pre-move do you ever play Kings
gambits did you just join the stream I
played Kings game with a few games ago
and it was really messy but I won wait
free rook he could take on that fall and
I'll take on or that play g3 nah
okay let's defend the F pawn first being
extra greedy now we'll trade so the only
thing I have to watch out for is getting
maded on g2 he's gonna do this or not
so always play f3 undermine the bishop
so I have a rook and three pawns for a
bishop decent and other material this
bishop is powerful what to do I mean
okay this is completely winning but I
just want to have like an easy position
I guess I'll just start pushing and I'll
do this and push what's my streaming
schedule you can go to my website or you
can type in exclamation point schedule
in the chat and you'll be linked hey we
have a solid Christian senior thanks for
subbing what to do
okay let's start put the rook behind the
pass pawn and push wait never play off
three or always play off three I will be
updating my schedule very shortly the
next event is the reddit Arena tomorrow
I think it's like their third or fourth
edition
the winner gets some mousepad so it's
gonna be very competitive okay the pawn
storm has arrived since when do I have a
schedule mmm since like the beginning of
the year probably I went through a dry
period in December I was playing a few
tournaments wait he wants to play this I
mean it's still completely winning I
could let's just fork Queen defends her
rook tried to pull a Carlson hope that I
don't see the backwards Queen move hey I
broke 2,400 my life is complete
good game yeah it's fun to play the
London when black doesn't really know
what to do a few points for black first
of all don't play a six I can give a
simple line maybe this will benefit
people if you don't know what to play
against London play c5 I do the setup
usually white will play C cream its bits
from DQ'd thanks for the bits so get
this position play Bishop d6 Bishop g3
and now very nice move Queen c7
and idea is actually very simple to play
Knight bTW 1705 and it's actually very
hard for light to stop most players will
do this you can do this and like a five
is pretty much guaranteed and a black
should equalize and Blackwell castle
have some space advantage whoa it's more
subs John Davis gifting a hundred Tier
one subs it's happening again look at
this also yes he asked a question like
right before I'm trying to find it I
think it's like he asked a question that
was trying to hide it I'm trying to find
it
did you catch the hikaru and levee
stream yesterday with blindfold 960 f3
in my game hearing them trying to reason
out where the pieces were yeah I was
actually watching part of that it was
really entertaining um thank you so much
for the 100 subs I wonder I mean that's
gotta be like most of the people because
a lot of people who are watching were
already suggs
do I read off these names I was also
watching the narrowed its key stream
yesterday where you gifted him a hundred
sub or two hundred subs and he was
trying to read off all of them okay I
love trying to meet off some of them
I'll read off as many as I can until I
lose my voice or until the scroll thing
stops working
it says Cajun 97 Benedetto rate Brandon
Ken arey theta Abe Frohman the real
donkey pride Sh'ma garma the shadowlight
zoo - Zooey's besom tech gambino wallaby
nice game bro Circo treadin legit lob
okay it's too much welcome to all the
subs all the new subs you should think
GM John Davis
again
speechless let's play another game I
have 48 pending challenges
what do I do command shift option
command whatever math dot random well
can I show if you want to see the J s
code it's looks like this and then you
just do that I'm not going to do it
again because I think it would accept
another challenge so oh I'm playing DQ'd
who just like cheered a hundred bits and
I'm playing against a London so what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to play the line
that I just showed so now we'll have a
lesson how so play against the London
and hopefully we get into it yes I am
allowing him to sign okay this is fine
next time donate less subs because I
don't 100 names I tried my best
it's not easy to read okay so I'm
following my own advice playing Queen c7
I just showed this position Joe Bruno
subscribed shout out to Joe oh you can
only max at 100 didn't know that okay so
my opponent clearly knows my plan but
can you stop my Plan B 5 is on the
horizon
now I'm not not actually sure if I
should castle and then play e5 or play
e5 right away because it depends what
white does
it was fun watching me got frustrated
with Siri you get joy out of my
frustration good still like ask Siri
things that are relevant I want to make
more tea but I forgot to use a the
kettle thing a little bit left I think I
bought this like combo herbal tea pack
like five different types of tea and
they're all like herbal like sleepytime
honey sleepytime peppermint probably not
the best thing to use to stay awake so
I'm gonna castle because i dont think
blacc can stop this move next i want to
gather up t8 and it's not anything like
so amazing but it will equalize it'll
give me a solid position my uptime is
slightly over an hour
ah John is a real developer Oh F or so
moves the epon before I can move my e
pawn now the question is do I play e5
and just make life really confusing for
all of us let's do it
usually you should calculate a move like
this because white can take in so many
different ways but on the next move I'll
be able to take on so many different
ways and it's just a mess but a key
factor in this position it's just a
simple observation Vikings here his King
is here which means rook e8 can come in
like so many different
minds we're in whites king will be a
target if like castles and I'll have to
think I'm glad that's
you
I'm so sorry wait you can't hear me
do I actually break it ah one sec wait
you mixer oh you can you can hear me now
okay I'm so sorry
r.i.p it's good how its back delay okay
yeah there's a slight delay that's
completely unintentional
yeah counseling is actually interesting
because now I don't have these rookie
eight lines and now I have so many moves
like even c4 could be a move I mean I
want to take eventually f5 I could just
play b5 and win Connect four that would
be too easy okay so I mean I have to
like commit myself to calculating takes
takes takes takes if I five it's a bit
weakening his Bishop g5 check so take
six six six I could take on d4 we trade
bishops maybe we don't trade bishops he
just takes back don't really see that
leading too much if I take here takes
takes takes maybe I could win the pawn
yeah there's lines where if he takes on
g6 I'm winning d4 so if take stakes if I
take on g3 takes back with H pawn takes
on e4 or ticks with Knights I mean we're
just trading I'll have neither six and
rook to e8 and maybe
I don't really want to spend so much
time my opponent's rated 1483 he's
actually playing like a decent game so
far and see for also interesting bishops
he - I feel like was this a guy who
asked like what what you do when they
play c4 in the London I feel like he
asks a question not sure though takes
takes I'm gonna start with this we'll
see what white is up to
I don't play DotA
I don't play anybody's these video games
not even fortnight's the other games i
play
apart from chess are war games like
Scrabble I've considered streaming like
Scrabble or or boggle my two favorites
maybe I'll do a boggle stream someday
trying to think what else I've played in
the past yeah I recently it's been
mostly chess rook e1 so he wants to play
e5 I could play c4 what's full-contact
possible even know if I want to ask I
feel like I'm winning upon because I'm
currently up a pawn we can just start
trading everything
I don't want white to activate so I can
take on c3 with an e5 plate rook e1
takes takes takes I don't know maybe
I'll just take here trade
I'll admit that one of my biggest
weaknesses in chess is calculating like
these very weird positions or there's
just so many lines to keep track of like
naka can just do it instantly it takes
work looking at c4 likes e4 e5 takes
takes takes trade I'm up upon in the end
maybe I can go for that
Camas like Bishop Bishop d2 d3 if Bishop
to be one maybe I take first let's start
with c4 I'm relying on some intuition
though John Davis is leaving I've fallen
behind in the chats have a good night or
good Bishop
whenever here into his night bought
secretly FBI this is really hard to keep
up I do request that people stick with
English language and the chats it's hard
to moderate other languages thanks again
John Davis for the subs thinking emote
is is do for John Davis have a lot of
you like I have so many more Iman emotes
slots now if anyone has emo suggestions
let me know either in the chats or on my
discord I have a channel
The Last Samurai yeah The Last Samurai
has an amazing Johnny data see most
people should just subscribe to The Last
Samurai
he used to emote Knight takes e4 was
slightly unexpected because now I'm up a
piece there's really no time for a 5v5 I
just take it do you have your trips do I
have all of my trips around the world
plan for the future
not at all my last trip most of the
countries I went to I booked my flight
like just a few weeks in advance
it was very bad planning it's actually
nice like to be completely flexible
because I can kind of change my mind
last minute oh do I do
queen let's move the Queen somewhere
safer and trying to be greedy though
what do I do what's let's play Queen c7
attacking the bishop expecting this I'll
still be up a piece or complete
development make my pieces happy started
geeking out with a software developer
talk you don't have to be sorry there is
a stage in my life for like two years I
was majoring in computer science and
doing a lot of coding got a lot of
coding but just wasn't my passion let's
play Knight b6 or it wasn't my biggest
passion I was passionate about it when I
was involved with it
amazing emote
you hate playing someone whose ratings
1100 or 2200 does that make you like
1,600 Oh someone again asking about two
Knights attack against the French yeah
I'm actually working on like a rapper
tour course so I might just be saving it
for that or if I go back to st. Louis
chess club and do a lecture for them I
would want to see my material so but so
many people asked about it maybe I
should just do something for YouTube
okay let's put their work on d8 first
attacking the Queen and then I'll have
the d5 square nicely controlled whoa a
thousand bits from Henry Lord Watson tea
money can buy some nice to you with that
thanks Henry Lord Watson I'm open for
tea recommendations wait JJ you're from
Turkey I heard people from Turkey like
know their tea like inside and outs
I was watching YouTube videos earlier
like how to make Turkish tea and it
sounded really complicated like you use
these two pots and you put water in one
pod and then the leaves in another pot
it seems like so much to learn
that leaves British tea bubble tea I had
bubble to you the other day but it
wasn't the healthiest it's so much sugar
and not enough bubbles okay let's not
get needed each seven is a target
there's ideas of this miss what to do
good move back kind of where I came from
honey lemon tea actually you know it's
good it is honey lemon ginger tea where
you just by like Raj injure raw lemons
and raw honey and you just like kind of
combine it and you make tea out of its I
completely forgot about nine of five
good thing I have this move defending
mates defending against the threat of
Knight takes c6 so there is increment in
this game there's an eight second
increment shift the board over a little
bit I should make a tea channel my
discord like once I'm more knowledgeable
I'll probably start making like some tea
review videos for you to try and expand
beyond the chess community the chess
audience just kind of played this
instinctively solid move defend f7 I'm
very soon I mean rook t3 is an idea
Knight a5 is an idea pieces can come to
life a six is a move let's play f6
because always play off six rip d3 still
looming if he plays a knight f7 I just
let it be
and I'll just think dance around the
nights do chess and T go hand-in-hand
yeah or hand in brain let's play Knight
d5 I should really start going for some
attack I have an extra piece I have a
time advantage I have tricky ideas of
this he's gonna play rook d7 such a
juicy move I he saw my threats so let's
move can I get away with that
rookie five rook g7 we trade it's better
but let's start with this
I should play John Botha both
Bartholomew who at Eva's coffee match
way Queen d2 free queen is he always
drinking coffee I feel like he's had tea
or he just has Starbucks people probably
know better than me I went through a
Starbucks Coffee phase recently at
Starbucks I've been getting the London
Fog it's so good like slightly sweet
okay Brooke here good pre move that okay
good game DQ'd I guess I'll share
another London secrets hey it's a sub
but I didn't see the message behind that
I think it was an old sub - whoa oh this
is uh so the the sub notifications
finally ended from the 100 gifted subs
thanks again Lord Watson yeah I'll show
I'll share a secret here if you're white
and you're playing the London and you
see your opponent's playing this line
the move I like to recommend is Bishop
to b5 now if you play this would be five
you actually is if it should be five
here
or it might be Bishop b5 here actually
where you're trying to provoke knight c6
I'm pretty sure it's Bishop b5 here
where black can't play 97 because the
bishop would hang after knight c6 then
you can play this and most often you'll
get some line which transposes but if
you're gonna play this you kind of have
to know that the Bishop e5 line so main
line is usually when the bishops on d3
but this is also pretty venomous if
black doesn't know what he's doing my
favorite tea is something that probably
most people haven't heard of it's called
Egyptian licorice the only place I found
it as Whole Foods and Amazon which is
basically the same thing
it's like it's spicy but also slightly
sweet it's very good no caffeine
relaxing why doesn't he kick the bishop
in what position Oh in this position so
I'll share a line very nice line and
love-hate chess thanks for subbing so
let's imagine black plays a six which a
lot of people will do we can even use a
chess database yeah
the idea for white is just to take and
then play Queen a4 and this is very very
tricky like attacking the pawn there's
actually two threats in this position
and this is easy threats Black has a few
ways to defend but there's a b7
most-played move then like can unleash
the other threats which is taking and
then Queen a3 it just winds up on so
it's a fascinating line I get here and
then here I feel like I've had a few
games there's okay a lot of strong
players who've played this
and then if black takes on g3 then
usually whites happy to open H file
there's still some positional play so
there is a video on youtube of me
showing the slide after 97 and then
Bishop d3 which is the Carlson game Howe
Carlson played this on me chest too but
he's also played it in the Masters
database this game is amazing Carlsen
voseo Chooch and this game is amazing
because black players like natural move
I'll share a secret to which I don't
know if too many people know about but
there's a book by avrech who's like one
of the top chess authors on how to play
against d4 sidelines and I believe in
his book he recommends this for black
this line with b6 and I've had at least
ok at least two or three online games
and at least two over the board games
that went almost exactly like the
Carlsen Bozzio ditch game because from
this position the line is like very
forcing for the next like five to ten
moves like white just keeps initiative
every move every move makes a threat
like threatening the rook and now
threatening the bishop also threatening
the bishop like three different ways
black has to take on g3 and Carlsen took
hitting the pawn on each sudden still
initiative f5 and then beautiful finish
takes takes in c6 pretty sure I have
this in one at least one me chess game
oh maybe I had the different line wait a
minute I have oh I had this line where
after a bishop takes F to King G
exactitude this is also 96 so for anyone
who plays a London useful game to know
did you know Denmark is one of the
biggest producers of licorice I had no
idea I went to Denmark for a tournament
spent one day in Copenhagen I'm the rest
of the time in-house Singur a max attack
watch London system video and when
you're first to Hunger Games
keep it up this is not the game i beat
Magnus this is a game Magnus beat spacio
Chooch realizing that it doesn't show
the names but yeah Carlson was white
anyway do i maybe I'll do one more or a
few more challenges random oops what did
I just do I opened the counsel in the
wrong window okay random challenge just
to show people here's all the challenges
[Music]
cool so I'm going to open up my counsel
and I'm playing I'm playing an altar
bullet games okay I have to focus this
is rated to only 15 seconds no increment
get ready free pieces I'm gonna made on
each sudden guaranteed
that was quick I'll play one more game
just one okay let's play this this lets
made on each two again ooh interesting
move ooh that was nice
hey checkmate and 500 bits from nikolas
dojin
thanks for the bits when my challenge
was accepted I was so nervous I couldn't
even think straight
that's how I felt when I played Carlsen
like the second was it the second or no
is the first time I knowingly played him
I just got crushed it happens you just
have to take a deep breath and think
happy thoughts
alright new game ok so we have some
quick games let's mix it up
chat tell me what opening to play
give me a first move I'm waiting good
luck
Grob Helsley Nazli was the first one I
feel like he was just prepared for that
playing like Rob I'm gonna play the same
line I played the other day but in this
game I'm gonna treat it like a gambit
now I'm even if I see three if he takes
whoa was this so this is like a I don't
know even what this is I could play this
play this let's play this push some
pawns now the problem is I have a pawn
on g4 which is hanging so let's make it
not hanging and okay like this is a one
benefit of the grab as this Knight is
kind of stuck I have to go to e7 if it
wants to develop and now we could trade
oh gee if I was actually kind of hanging
there so let's play h4 we'll have some
French structure with my pawns far
advanced and without my dad bishop can't
complain try and get a night at four
Queen will come here maybe here dark
squares are nice
okay let's start with this and all these
people recommending normal openings wait
and some people recommending the Bond
Club I don't know if I've ever played
the Bond cloud if I did I don't have any
memory of it also it's getting really
late I'm getting tired and I have to
meet someone tomorrow I have to wake up
earlier tomorrow let's play let's just
continue upon swarming okay I just want
to trade bishops so I can Castle
queenside and gather rook another rooks
to the Kings I will also appreciate it
if a knight can land here
start by castling Wow
keep things closed so if takes with F
wanna win this pawn but still
complicated because takes there's a for
and that might just be bad for me
neither six rook takes f6 so let's play
a three creating lift for my king what
is the names of which is that knight c6
so defending the pawn and attacking upon
it's playing out of four if he takes on
g5 I take on e4 are some ideas of taking
and then winning the recommend
yeah let's keep the Queen along this
diagonal should play a rosin gambit move
free pawn there is one gambit I've
discovered which is actually quite
playable which there's so few games in
the database I just have never had a
chance to play it in a tournament I
prepared it for a few like strong
players who I were I was like half
expecting they would go into it I could
show it to people and then maybe it can
be named after someone else
it's a gambit on move 3s play Queen b1
trying to do something but where's my
something
black is solid for the time being okay
let's play this and win a night
this position is nice let's take here
upon this pinned throw-in a check this
is about to be meet I think if it were
just calm I could remove everything okay
opponent resigns good game tennis pal or
as a tennis paul but misspelled ball
thanks nicely for nilesy for suggesting
the grab again this time with some
success if people are curious I can show
the rosin gambits I'm just gonna claim
the name before anyone else does it
starts off as a London obviously all
right no it starts off with a six
because people who play e6 will
sometimes play the Dutch so white will
play a London and then after f5 oh I can
play g4 here and this is a bit different
than the other g4 lines and like the
Dutch because blacks committed t6 and g6
isn't always the most desirable and I've
done a bunch of analysis like takes here
I think the best one for black is g3
there's also oh there's such a crazy
line which like if you look at this with
stockfish it'll be one of the top lines
is black playing g5 I prepared this like
seriously for a tournament once where I
thought my opponent was gonna like at
least get into this position as
preparing g5 Bishop c1 and if you turn
on stockfish again one of the top moves
is h5 it's just insane
I think this is this is on like computer
like my chest base before their round
like how do you get this position move
for looks like whites only made two
moves
pretty sure you try this one of the top
stock fish moves that's up there like
whites clearly better because blacks
just overextending I don't think any
human would play g5 but yeah these lines
could be interesting especially if like
if takes at some point nice e3 and e4
it's like a Banco gambit but reflected
okay do I accept one more person
okay I'm gonna accept a person I want to
actually don't want to make this
difficult let's accept a person are
there any BOTS challenging me
there's no BOTS oh there's one what is
this is this horde
no it's crazy house so there's some
variance okay we're gonna do this
completely randomly okay playing this
guy hey midnight it's way past midnight
first time seeing your streams YouTube
chest content are greats well thanks for
the comments okay I'm gonna do what I
normally do
I'm pretty sure I played this today
against some GM's or no again some like
master level players got some good
positions White's not accepting the
gambit this is already fine for black I
really need an FAQ like section
somewhere because this is the most
common question I guess will I ever go
for GM maybe someday but not in the near
future maybe when I'm 40 because that's
what been Feingold did randomization is
best now let me ask are there any
developers in the chat because I have a
question is there a piece of code we can
write to accept a random twitch
subscriber out of like all the random
challenges because like all of these
people okay a lot of subscribers maybe
most are subscribers after though after
the appearance of John Davis but can we
just like limit it to subscribers so
that it's probably a way to do it whoa
there's a lot of people saying yes yes
yes
all these developers does twitch so
there's like giveaway BOTS but those are
a bit different where I just want to
like click a button and accept a new
challenge or like press enter
I guess yeah doing a giveaway maybe that
would be I'll be possible what about
poor people this have to watch
consistently and wait for the gift so
when I first started streaming i was
playing simon
but then i realized it wasn't that great
for the viewing experience it was fun
for people playing but viewing it's like
it's hard to keep track of have i played
marbles no cuz I lost all my marbles it
was devastating
we need IP detection system or a list of
their usernames to also have liked it
there should be like a wait list website
you just click the link you write down
your your username
marbles is a twitch game I played poker
poker commentator are you a poker
commentator yeah I like okay I'd like
strategy and word games mainly chess and
Scrabble okay so we have a position the
whites trying or was trying to attack I
don't fight still trying to attack kingi
two very suspicious land the knight on
c4 could tree move it pre move and see
what light does maybe I shouldn't maybe
I should I don't know I played dota no I
think I accidentally like labeled my
stream as like a dota game because I put
one of the tags as Auto chess which is
maybe some dota term but I did it
unknowingly Alberto wait what's this
name Alberto Lee ravioli I think I
mispronounced your name the last time I
probably still mispronounced it it's
going it's going well a little bit tired
but I'm about to win like he has two
legal moves one of them gets Forks the
other one gets me to choose your poison
yeah I have no idea with although chess
is like I typed in chess and then it was
just confusing Francisco yeah thanks for
the game and vit what's this name vilt
zu 0 3 thanks for the game I'm very
tired
I think I'm going to endings